The fact is that we're in a situation where we inherited a god-awful circumstance.
People are in real trouble.
We acted to move to bring relief to the people who need the most help now.
And in the process, we, in case you haven't noticed, we have strong disagreements.
You probably detected my frustration with their attitude about the American people.
My friend says that 30 percent of the American people are takers.
Romney points out 47 percent of the people won't take responsibility.
He's talking about my mother and father.
He's talking about the places I grew up in, my neighbors in Scranton and Claymont.
He's talking about the people that have built this country.
All they're looking for, Martha, all they're looking for is an even shot.
Whenever you give them the shot, they've done it.
They've done it.
Whenever you've leveled the playing field, they've been able to move.
And they want a little bit of peace of mind.
And the president and I are not going to rest until that playing field is leveled.
They, in fact, have a clear shot, and they have peace of mind...
...until they can turn to their kid and say with a degree of confidence,...
"...Honey, it's going to be okay."
It's going to be okay.
That's what this is all about.